Film Courage: Where do you struggle most with
writing screenplays?
R.L. Scott, Writer/Director: Interestingly
enough it’s just writing.
I think I’ve been writing for so long where
I’m at the point now where I wish there
was some really good software where I could
just talk and it would just write it in script
format for me you know.
The physical act of getting it out of your
head I think is the hardest part now because
it’s usually most creatives especially a
few storytellers there’s never a time when
you don’t have stories just constantly coming
into your head like ideas.
Even if you flush out the idea fully, it’s
just the physical act of typing.
I think that’s the thing when I was really
young it was fun you know just young and typing
and everything is great you can just type
for hours and hours everyday because I do
so many other things I think now I would just
really have that be automated.
I’m getting to a place now where I have
a few younger writers that I’m working with
where I can sort of outline the story not
for everything.
There are certain films where I’m like this
is just my baby right here but certain projects
where I’ll do an outline and then I’ll
send it to them and then they can write the
script based on my outline and then send it
back and I’ll just like punch it up.
So that’s been pretty cool.
I’m waiting on that magic thing where I
don’t have to type anymore.
Film Courage: What about writing in long form?
Is this appealing to you or no?
R.L.: When I started out it was on an old
school typewriter with the big keys that come
out…you know…[makes typing sounds].
That’s how I started out.
And then moved to the electric and then the
computer.
But I want to talk and have something typed
for me.
If I could never physically type another script
again I’d be great.
That would be awesome.
Film Courage: Is this because you don’t
like the screenplay format?
You’d almost rather do it in novel form?
R.L.: I think it’s just the physical act
because it takes so much brainpower to write.
It’s very exhausting.
It takes your soul.
I think it’s just that part of it.
I love telling stories and I still have a
lot of things I want to say but I think because
I still edit, I still shoot, I still direct,
I still do sound design, certain products,
because I’m doing all of that other stuff
when I physically have to type a script, I
might get a couple pages and I’m done.
Unless you are so in it and you’re to get
it out of your head, that’s different but
I try to set goals.
Because I’m older now and it’s harder
to write as much as I did before so I set
goals such as a certain amount of pages or
that sort of thing.
I try to do it where I break it into sections.
Right now I’m finishing up the ALMIGHTY
STREET TEAM, adapting those comic books into
a script and I’ve probably got 30 pages
left.
Like I’m almost there.
And that’s been difficult too adapting something
that already exists, a comic book or doing
an adaptation, it’s very different than
when you are coming up with something completely
original.
It’s riding that line of how much do you
keep, how much do you change, bringing it
from the comic book into live-action there
are certain things that are going to operate
differently.
That’s been a unique challenge.
This is the first time I’ve done that, adapted
anything that was pre-existing,
a unique challenge but very different because
I want to stay true to the spirit of the material
and there are great moments in the material
that you definitely want in there and then
certain places you have to sort of expand
it to make it work.
But I think I’ve found a really good space
with it.